you ever watch jackass as a kid dude
growing up with my brother we were
obsessed with the jackass crew like
jackass viva la bam wild boys featuring
stevo south floridian
native he came out of the the
swamp
the swap shop here in sunrise really
yeah he was a clown there and then
that's where they recruited him get out
of here yeah didn't know that he went he
um grew up in miami he went to um or
something like that okay we'll have to
do some research on it find that answer
anyway i remember watching jackass and i
remember thinking all right it was
hilarious the wild boy's awesome but i'm
like what happens when the cameras go
off oh boy i was so thankful above all
is that i could just the show was off i
could turn off the tv and knowing that i
didn't have to take these guys to the
hospital i didn't have to drive these
guys or go in an ambulance because you
know that [ __ ] was going on like that
you know there was broken bones
concussions issues limbs being torn off
you know that was happening and part of
the beauty of jackass is not having to
deal with these guys and be like dude my
friend just got bit by a shark
that kind of stuff exactly um
anyway when i saw this article and it
has money it has to do with money
insurance uh net worth has all the good
stuff entertainment i want to get into
this it says look the jackasses are old
now you know it's been 21 years since
jackass started
wow jackass 25 yeah exactly jackass
legally allowed to drink now
and they revealed
how much money they've racked up on
medical bills
over the years wow take a guess do you
want a guest or should i just get into
it it's already on the tv okay there it
is the jackass crew has racked up more
than 24
million dollars
in medical bills alone
since being part of jackass just medical
bills 24
million dollars so
you know they paid
quite the hefty price
in bodily injury and absurd for their
absurd antics in fact
almost 25 million dollars worth okay
so
um
this is what i'm talking about their
their medical bills could have gone to
one of these colleges
exactly
so
because i always think these guys
they're [ __ ] their lives up they're
messing their bodies up
of unproportionate magnitude
and then you're just like oh we'll see
you next week here at the wild boys yeah
the next week on jackass it's like i
hope you're alive for that episode
steven i don't know how i mean well rest
in peace ryan dunn he passed away
unrelated to that by the way how did he
die he was in a car accident he was one
of my favorite guys i don't want to i
don't want to say if he was uh he was
drinking and driving or anything like
that but he was okay speeding so he's
the only one that that's past one that's
and unrelated to any of these things
that's crazy
um so we're going to talk about who do
you think of all the people of jackass
is at the top of this 24 million the
largest percentage went to one specific
person i want to say 8 million of the
24. 8 million of the twenty-four it's
between two of them it's either between
knoxville himself or
our boys steve-o who are you going
who's your guess oh i'm gonna go with
stevo
and you would be
dead wrong johnny knoxville eight mill
8.6 million dollars
worth in medical treatment
uh he's number one on the jackass injury
list there he is
he was bit by an alligator he had a
brain hemorrhage he had a dozen broken
bones and 16 concussions
16 concussions that's like there's 16
games in the nfl i think there's
actually 17 now typically 16. that's
getting a concussion in every single
game there's no way that his brain is
working fine right now
um
but he's still like high functioning he
does other films he like well they're
doing another jackass are they okay yes
well let's talk about that let's talk
about was it worth it
to mess up your body
right to have all this medical trip all
these concussions
was it worth it in the end let's talk
about this johnny knoxville
by the way all these guys are in their
40s or 50s at this point yeah i think
they're okay johnny knoxville is 50
years old
he's by far and away the wealthiest
member of jackass clearly right he's the
main guy yeah how much you think he's
worth
oh man
all those injuries have to be pay him a
lot uh i want to say a crazy number like
uh
50 million dollars more 75 million holy
hell okay and it's not even close the
rest of the crew
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro